うわ緊張するなぁ
久々にこういう動画撮るとちょっと緊張し
ますねえーこんにちははじめしゃちょー
です
[音楽]
こんにちは
皆さんお久しぶりですはいなんか最近企画
系の動画バンバン出してたんであんまり
こういうなんか個人的な話することないん
で久々にちょっと真面目真面目じゃないん
ですけども皆さんにねほんと動画の
タイトル通りなんですけどもちょっとお
聞きしたいことがありまして意見を聞きた
いって感じですはい
次にしろって言ったらそこまでなんです
けどもみんなに見てもらって成り立ってる
のではじめしゃちょー一応どういう感じな
のかなっていうのをお聞きしたくて
ちょっと動画を撮っております
割と僕の中では
結構今後の
YouTubeのあり方を左右するような
内容ではあるんでもしよかったら動画を見
てってくださいよろしくお願いします
すいませんね最近動画も盛りだせてなくて
8月も追いつきまして8月
久々にもうほぼ毎日投稿で動画バーって
出して結構ね再生数もドカンといて
うわーって言ってなんか久々に萌え限った
んですよYouTuber魂が
で燃え尽きまして8月ほんとに
YouTubeのことだけ考えていろんな
そのお仕事だったりYouTube以外の
仕事を結構ストップさせてもらって9月
10月に他のいろんな
YouTube以外のお仕事をこなす期間
だったりとかちょっとまあ
サボったりとかサボってるわけじゃない
ですもちろんいろんな仕事をさせて
いただいてたんですけどもちょっと
YouTuberストップするんですけど
も
来たり11月そろそろそろそろ外れました
復活しようかなと思いまして10月の最後
にちょっとYouTube全く頑張ろうと
いう動画を撮ってるわけでございますで
今回
皆さんに聞きたいことがありまして何かと
いうと動画編集のあり方ですはいいつも
はじめしゃちょーのチャンネル見てる
みんな
ありがとう
本当ありがとうであるんですけどもいつも
見てる方がお気づきでしょうか僕1年2年
前ぐらいから
実は
喋ってる言葉ほとんど文字に起こしてるん
ですよ
[音楽]
気づきましたあの気づいてなかったら全然
いいんですよ気づいてなかったらあの
登録と高評価だけして書いていただいて
気づいてた人いるかわかんないんですけど
も実は僕が喋ってることは全部文字起こし
してるんですよちょっと今からやってみ
ますねはいこんな感じで喋ってる言葉が
全部こう
文字として出るんですよ
1年前ぐらいから実は
喋ってる言葉をこういう感じで全部文字
起こししてるんですよ見やすいでしょ僕も
見やすいと思ってやってるんですよなぜ
なら電車とかで音が聞こえない時にも
聞けるからっていう目安さんの点でも結構
いろんなYouTuberはもうこうやっ
てものすごくしてるんですけどもこの
スタイルになったのが本当にね去年か2年
前かぐらいここ最近ですなんですけども
本当は56年前の僕の動画見てください
こちらどうぞ皆さん
宝くじ買いましたか
まさか買ってない
宝くじ当たる確率は非常に低いんですけど
も皆さん買わないとそもそも取らないです
よ
買わないと当たんないからだよどんなに
低い確率でも必ず
宝くじを買わないと当たる人たちの中に
すら入れないっていうことはあの買って
ない皆さんはもうダメですただ僕はもう
買ってあるんで当たる当たらないにしろ
買うことに意味があると思っていますもう
買わないと当たる可能性がゼロになって
しまうんでこれは何を言いたいんだろう
ほぼ文字起こしてないんですよもちろん
テキストとかあるんですけどもこう
しゃべった言葉は私言っておりますねはい
喋ったことが出てると思いますこういう
感じにこういう感じで喋った言葉が文字
起こし
全くしてなくてちょっと編集疲れるんで
やめます15年前はもうほぼなし文字
起こしになしで自分から始めたことなん
ですけどももちろん欲しいいるかいらない
か説っていうの最近ちょっと思っていまし
て
いる方がいいとは思うんですよ間違いなく
あった方が見やすいし音聞けない状態でも
楽しめるんですけども
編集がやばいんですよ
YouTuberさんなら分かると思うん
ですけどももう少しの編集
えぐくくていや本当にエグい最近僕の動画
見てもらったら分かると思うんですけども
動画の尺が結構長かったりするんですよ
もう20分30分の動画の文字起こし
間違いなく1人だと無理で文字起こして
なかったら結構1人でも動画作れるんです
よ毎日ただその文字起こしだったり最近の
動画の尺が長かったりもちろんそもそも
YouTube映画のお仕事の時間があっ
たりで
正直
喋った言葉を全部持つに起こしてると
かなり動画出せなくなります
スタッフ増やせてなるほどスタッフやせっ
ていうお言葉ありますもちろんスタッフ
増やしてます8月のほぼ毎日動画出してる
時は僕も含めて56人体制で実は事務所の
編集部屋貸し切って1週間ぐらいずっと
編集合宿とかもしてて実はそれでなんとか
毎日間に合ったぐらいの
ほんとギリギリのギリギリで作業してたし
その作業のほとんどが文字起こしなんです
よスタッフもっと増やしてって思うかも
しれませんけどすいませんねあのやっぱ
クリエイターでこだわり強くて結構細かい
んですよそこビックリマーク使うのとか
なんか笑い声をWあの草生やすのにするか
とか
丸とか漢字カタカナ結構細かい指摘を出た
スタックにしててそれ覚えるのに結構期間
かかってなんかそもそも何人かスタッフ
いるのに文字起こしのためにさらに増やす
必要があるのかとまあ今は編集スタッフ僕
も含めて456人体制で実は編集してるん
ですけども
どうですかはじめしゃちょー的には最近
自分の動画見返して昔の動画とか見て思っ
たんですけどなんか今本当
流れでなんとなくみんな
文字起こしてるなっていう
気もしてちょっと僕も若干影響を受けて
やってるんですけど見やすいしね普通に
そもそも見やすいのが全然あるんですけど
も
50個性知ってるんですけども
正直どこしてなくていいよって言われたら
えっと動画4枚増えると思います結構ガ
チってこうガチでもう30分の持つ残しと
か普通に喋った言葉全部テキスト打つの
やばくて昔の僕の動画を見返した感じ
正直なくていいんだったらやめたいなくて
いいんだったらない方がいいかなって思い
ますただ見やすいじゃん本当に
文字起こし
落となくても楽しめるわけですよで思って
たんですけどもやっぱり映像って音ありき
なんですよ
文字起こしだと伝わらない面白さとかある
じゃん喋り方とかこんにちは
ー
字幕とか実際にこの声の感情を聞いて
初めて分かることもあると思うのでなんか
ここにねぐらい喋った言葉を全部文字に
起こしてとんでもない時間をスタッフと
みんなで頑張ってた結果全員喋った言葉は
なくすと動画の投稿頻度はめちゃくちゃ
上がるかなって思ってます皆さんはどう
思いますか全然モツしてくださった方が
ありがたいっていう意見ももちろんあり
ますてか俺もそうそれがいいと思ってやっ
てるわけだから今ただね
忙しいなかなかとてもじゃないけど二度と
毎日動画を出せないと思ってますただ僕の
動画って
喋る動画というより
映像で見せるというか本当変なことを動画
にするんで
意地からは強いと思うんでそんなに文字
起こしなくてもいいのかなとも思いつつ
なんかね
皆さん突然昨日のハロウィンの動画とか見
ました実は結構昔のスタイルに寄せてて
文字起こしとか少なめにしたんですよああ
いう感じに戻るというイメージね突然
あんな感じに戻すとうわ何で初めなんか
最近のがハロウィンぐらいからなんか
手抜きになってんじゃんって言われそうな
んで一応ちゃんと説明しようと思って動画
を撮ってます
手抜きじゃないです本来の姿の本来の姿だ
と思っていただきたいんですけど
とりあえず
俺はどっちでもいいやりたいことは
引き続きやりますけどもやっぱり見て
くれるのはみんななんでみんなの意見も
聞いておきたいなっていう感じですそれも
踏まえて決めようと思うし完全にこうしま
すっていうとそれしなきゃいけなくなる
から
様子見つつまた編集の仕方は変えていこう
と思ってるんですけどつまんねこの裏の
事情を話して裏の事情を話してるんです
けど見てくれるのはみんなだからどう思っ
てるんだろうなっていうのを正直
気になってるのでちょっと聞いてみました
もちろん最終的には自分で決めるんです
けど
難しいねYouTuberの動画編集って
答えがない世界だからこればかりは
ちょっとわかんないなと思いますけどね
なんか最近すごい前の俺の動画見返してて
なんか
文字なくてもやっぱ面白いもの面白いなっ
て思ったし俺に求められてるのは東北力
じゃなくもう
ここですね
脳内こいつまたやべえことやってんなって
いう企画もっとたくさんやれたら嬉しいな
と思って皆さん是非ご意見くださいあの
ほんと相談ですというわけで皆さん11月
になりますねそろそろ年末ですねゆっくり
できたしネタも結構たまってできたので
そろそろYouTube復活しようかなと
思いますここ最近びっくりするぐらい投稿
頻度悪かったんですけどもそういう実は裏
の話もあるよっていうことですはいなんか
こういう感じで終わるのだな最後に1個
だけじゃあ特別な
暴露いきます最近
美容外科に行ってきましたじゃあな
[音楽]